You know, I'm not for people mocking
Islam just to mock it and insult it.
All right, but I am for saying the truth
and bringing up issues that are
problematic like I did. Okay, that's
legitimate stuff and talking about it.
And to to try to shut that down by
calling it whatever Islamophobic. Yeah,
well, that's that's when we know you
have an agenda. I believe in free
speech. If you want to burn a Quran or
whatever, I don't care about that, but I
myself, that's not what I'm looking at
here. I'm talking about how they want to
shut down actual free thinking and free
speech. And as it happens, the problem
with Islam, I've said this many times
before, is it's built on a it's a house
of cards. It's so easily collapsed. And
that's why it has all these safeguards,
uh, blasphemy and apostasy. You can't
Everything I've said is blasphemy, okay?
Not because it's true, it's not true,
but because it might make a Muslim
question their faith. We can't have
that. Okay? Because there are so many
questions if you look at Islam and its
prophet and how everything he said and
what the Quran says.
Um, so we can't have you thinking
outside the box. You have to go by our
interpretation. It's not what you think,
it's not what's plainly in front of you.
Um, because yeah, if you do go with
that, Islam collapses. So it needs all
these safeguards. Same thing with
apostasy. Yusuf al-Qaradawi, one of the
most famous theologians, Egyptian, he
died a few years back, but he said if it
wasn't for the law of apostasy, Islam
would have died in its cradle, which is
true. Uh, he was referring to the
apostasy wars after Muhammad died.
So many Arabs who had who were nominal
Muslims tried to break away. And then
there was the apostasy wars under Abu
Bakr, the first caliph, to bring back
Muslims into the fold of Islam lest they
get crazy thoughts about, you know,
breaking away. Same thing with the
blasphemy. You can't ask too many
questions. You know, don't rock the
boat, right? Um, so yeah. And it's
interesting because that is also how the
so-called left operates. They too are in
a house of cards. If people can think
and are not censored constantly, they're
going to realize that so much of leftist
talking points, as they're called are
just uh, have no foundation, okay? So,
we have to create blasphemy codes
against Western people. It's not called
blasphemy, of course, but it's called
hate speech, right? Just like
Islamophobia. Oh, you can't think that
cuz that's hate, right?
So, yeah, there's something about these
creeds, whether they're secular or
religious,
that insist on hate speech codes. Yeah,
the reality is they're so weak and uh
there's that if anyone casts any
question about them, they crumble and
fall apart. That's why. So, the rest of
us are supposed to play this game by
calling their censorship hate speech cuz
we're so concerned about human rights.
If those UN people
who created the Islamophobia combat
awareness day, March 15th, and it's all
positive it's in completely human rights
language and jargon. And if those people
really thought of it as a human rights
thing, where were they for all those
Christians who were being killed, the
list that I gave you, that long list,
and who are being killed right now in
the moment? Why don't they ever talk
about them? If this is really about
human rights, irrespective of religion.
That's what they claim, right? They
don't care about who believes what. We
just want to preserve your human rights.
And yet not a word for the Christians
who are being mass slaughtered and
carnage, right? But we want to we want
to talk about hate speech against Islam.
Yeah, you mean you want to shut down
real criticism against Islam because
there's no response other than to shut
people down, right? It should be obvious
at this point. Bring back the
>> [music]
>> fire.
Bring
back the
back the fire
and the
>> [music]
>> righteousness.